we don't hire people to grow our
business we hire people to buy back our
time well I don't have time though to
actually sit down and figure this out
that's my favorite one where do I spend
my time on things and of those
activities what actually generates the
most income and what lights me up 80
done by somebody else is 100 freaking
awesome but the moment you have somebody
actually do work that's better than you
would have done it's an unlock for
people it takes that ceiling of
complexity and just blows It Wide Open
I'm fired up for this episode of the
think media podcast because you're gonna
be breaking down some tips for hiring
help as a content creator even if you
can't afford it yet and research shows
that small business owners are wasting
on average 22 hours per week and so
imagine what you could get done with 22
extra hours in this episode Dan Martell
who's got almost 100 000 subscribers on
YouTube but that's not even your thing I
mean you're a 5x founder of businesses
you've had three exits you're a husband
father an athlete coming from Canada and
here we are in Las Vegas recording the
podcast and you recently wrote a brand
new book called buy back your time get
unstuck reclaim your freedom and build
your Empire I'm so fired up to dig into
your tips for how we can actually build
teams even if we think we can't afford
it hire help boost our productivity but
before we get into all of that I need to
know more about this story your mom
found drugs money stolen guns at your
house and she called the cops I write
that in the book what's even happening
tell me about this story yeah it was uh
I I grew up in um you know I kind of
explained to people they're like so were
you in gangs or like what happened and I
just I think I was just like super
hyperactive I got diagnosed with ADHD
when I was a young kid and we grew we
grew up in a kind of a neighborhood out
in the country and I just had a lot of
Just Energy and uh it got to a place
where
you know had an anger issue growing up
my dad was in sales so he was always
gone my mom was an alcoholic and I found
this out later in my my kind of mid teen
years I didn't understand kind of how
she acted or why she acted certain ways
and um and my life just spiraled out of
control when I was 13 when I discovered
you know drugs and became an addict and
ended up in prison when I was 15 the
first time got out promise I would
change my ways find a new group of
friends I think I lasted 20 hours like
literally that night right back at it
and um and then just things got crazy
and I was just spending time with people
twice my age you know motorcycle gangs
types Sons of Anarchy style right wow
yeah in Eastern Canada yeah everything
came to uh ahead when I remember my
brother called me to tell me not to come
home because my mom had called the
police because she had found some some
guns in my room and some drugs and some
money and I decided to steal a car and
go on the run and and the whole time
like this lasted over two day period
where I was just like high and drunk
driving around you know heading to uh
Montreal Canada
and I took a exit off the highway and
there was a routine roadblock checking
insurance and driver's license and I
decided to make a run for it and before
I stole the car I had a handgun sitting
next to me and I said to myself that if
the cop stopped me I'm just gonna pull
the gun and let them take my life
and that's what happened I smashed into
the side of a house went for the gun and
for whatever reason it got stuck wow
that is a powerful story and it's
powerful because I mean I think it's
kind of an extreme example of how
anybody can turn their life around
though because to go from that this most
extreme situation and really being a
criminal to crushing it as an
entrepreneur and I'm inspired by a lot
of things that you know the your
athleticism and different things you're
into there and so now you've built all
these businesses you're really renowned
for software as a service you got a lot
of SAS content and you help those
Founders but you've got this expertise
of helping people get out of the
overwhelm helping people start buying
their time back and first question is
who should you hire first like which as
a founder and so to Define founder two a
lot of people listening to this might be
accidental entrepreneurs or they didn't
really found anything there might be a
network marketing or they're in real
estate or a loan officer and they want
to use YouTube to get leads client sales
but they're nevertheless the principal
right there they could be the CEO they
might not Define themselves that way but
now they need help and they need help
with this content thing who do you
recommend hiring first it all comes down
to like what you're spending your time
on right and it doesn't it's actually
interesting because I wrote the book for
a very specific you know uh 1.2 million
in Revenue 12 to 13 employees agency
owner like I had a very specific
archetype but I wrote it in a way
hopefully that was going to resonate
with creators Freelancers
c-level people at companies directors
like what happens at the end of the day
is is like people create value per hour
of unit of time right and I start the
book by talking about the different
levels of trading your time and time for
money and then money for money
eventually so every person can just look
at their calendar and say where do I
spend my time on things and of those
activities what actually generates the
most wealth or income and what lights me
up so to me the best person to hire
first is all the things that you don't
like to do that you could pay people the
least amount of money to support you so
if somebody's you know an employee at a
company but you're making good money
maybe it's having somebody support you
in your home right and taking care of
the house cleaning and the meal prep and
you know supporting you in that way if
it's if you're an entrepreneur for most
of the founders that I work with uh it's
usually your inbox in your calendar
because your inbox is full of you know I
always say your inbox is a public to-do
list for strangers to demand of your
time like it's kind of nutty to think
about it but if we are back you know 100
years in business and you're on Main
Street USA you wouldn't allow a stranger
to just walk into your office and demand
something from you but yet in today's
world that's how we do it so it really
depends on the individual's calendar of
where they're spending their time and
and it's really that that filter of like
what's the least expensive thing you
hate to do because when you take things
that suck your energy out of your life
and you start stacking what I call Green
activities the ROI on that is not even
just like buying the time back it's
actually an amplifier to the work you
get to do because you go from thing to
thing or project to project with a new
sense of excitement and passion and that
that energy is compounding it's not just
more money but it's also quality of life
Peace of Mind happiness yeah so in the
book you do recommend that for most
Founders it's probably an admin
assistant
this is what happens is we're taught a
bunch of beliefs that are just not true
okay and I have a whole chapter called
the five time assassins where I try to
break down these these beliefs around
like you know when I start in business
my dad would say stuff to me like you
know the CEO they're the Chief sandwich
maker and office cleaner and they've got
to be willing to do the stuff to show
the rest of the team that they're and I
don't disagree but at a certain point if
that's 10 to 15 hours if I own a
CrossFit gym and I'm spending 10 to 15
hours of my week managing the
cleanliness of my classes and the space
and putting equipment away and instead
of coaching where that coaching hour
could be worth a hundred to five hundred
dollars an hour why would you do that
trade like where what is what are you
trying to prove to anybody what I would
much rather and I talked about this uh
bike owner in the book he owned the bike
shop that I go to frequently and he had
this belief that he had to be the guy
that you know welcomed me at the front
door and shook my hand and was like how
you doing Dan and knew about my family
but at the same time everything I
ordered every every time I brought my
bike in for maintenance every time I do
anything in business there was always a
mistake there was always an issue and I
remember thinking to myself it's like
I appreciate you want to do that but
what I actually want you to do more is
just run your business better and to
have any other person that you could
just say hey when people walk through
that door can you please put on a smile
and shake their hand
and just get your staff to do that so
that you can be in your office and run
the company that's actually what your
customers want so there's just a lot of
beliefs around it and when I look at
most people's calendar they're just
spending a lot of time on 10 tasks and
what I've learned is you can't build a
million dollar company running around
doing 10 tasks it's just it's
mathematically impossible so you share
the buyback rate calculation what is the
buyback principle first yeah the buyback
principle states this and this is the
controversial things we don't hire
people to grow our business we hire
people to buy back our time because if
you do the first you don't get the
second but if you do the second you get
the first and it's a I call it a
capacity over calendar problem is a lot
of first-time entrepreneurs are just
like I'm busy I need to hire people I
need to hire a person in the office I
need to hire a person in the warehouse I
gotta hire a support person I need to
hire a programmer got to hire somebody
to create logos but it's like no you can
do those activities because those are
like hiring a designer to do logos for
you might have to pay them 35 50 bucks
an hour but what you're going to still
do Eight dollar ten dollar you're gonna
run one of my friends in construction
and I remember he was overwhelmed and I
was just like tell me about your
overwhelm and in his explanation of his
week I identified that he spent two days
a week running around site to site to
site and I'm like dude that's called a
runner that's a person you can hire
part-time a kid because all you're doing
is literally taking equipment from one
place another place and while they're
doing that you could be on calls with
potential new customers hiring better
team members training your team but
these are not things that you do but
it's just I think sometimes we just get
addicted to the activity it's like email
it's like is that really the best use of
your time no but at least I know that
when I wake up if I just like follow it
I'll feel productive but it's a false
sense of productivity because it
actually doesn't move your goals and
dreams forward so the buyback principle
is we start by hiring people to buy back
time out of our calendar and by doing
that then we fill it with stuff that
makes us more money that lights us up
and that'll support us having more
resources to actually build the business
so then you have What's called the
buyback rate calculation so those people
could be thinking well I don't I can't
afford to have somebody help me for a
lot of content creators they should hire
a video editor is maybe one of those
first things that was what did it for me
I was spending when I had a video it
took me four to eight hours to edit it
when I stopped doing that I recovered a
ton of time bananas and if it was
multiple videos I could recover 30 to 40
hours a week by no longer editing video
but what is the buyback rate calculation
to maybe determine if you should hire
and what you can afford so last night
dinner I had an awesome meal with the
creators got about 2 million subs and
this was the conversation we had and and
because they brought it up like I'm a
lighthouse not a tugboat and unless you
ask me about it I'm not gonna but I see
it all around me and here's the math and
I don't want to lose people because I'm
going to make them do some math right
it's essentially your income so whatever
you make personally so I always say it's
your if your salary it's the profit in
your business and then discretionary
expenses because nobody wants to pay
taxes so they put a lot of personal
stuff there which is fine but that's
still value that you create on an
annualized basis no doubt so you take
that amount of money and let's just use
a simple number like a hundred thousand
dollars seventy thousand salary twenty
thousand profit ten thousand
discretionary expenses as a general rule
of thumb then we divide that by two
thousand because there's two thousand
hours in a normal working year when you
take weekends away and holidays and
stuff most people work two thousand
hours now that'll give you what I
sometimes call the value creation score
like what is your hour actually
producing per year but you can't use
that as the number to go hire people
because then you're literally just
trading you for somebody else which
means you'll build a business but then
you won't make any money yeah so a lot
of entrepreneurs create businesses that
they grow to hate yes because they hire
above them my whole philosophy is higher
below and that raises you that raises
your ability to produce so is it a video
editor maybe unless they're spending a
lot of time in other areas and there's
10 hours they could buy back at a lower
cost outtasking right so it's kind of
like you stack so is it a video editor
maybe but it may be somebody else first
then the video editor or somebody else
and that's what I was explaining to this
person last night because like when I
asked them how much he was making in his
his YouTube channel like the and he was
like well how much would I have to pay a
good editor I'm like there's no amount
of money that it wouldn't make sense
when you're telling me you're spending
30 hours a week editing like you're
making a lot of money and and when you
look at it it has nothing to do with
that trade so the formula is 2000 you
divide that that's your value per hour
then you divide it by four because I
want you to get a four times Roi on the
buyback yeah so if you hire somebody to
clean your house and you pay them you
know 500 bucks a week because they come
a couple times then you've bought back
eight hours now what do you do with
those new eight hours to go invest in
your business or invest in your health
or invest in your relationships it
doesn't have to be always a monetary
thing because the last chapter in the
book's actually the buyback lifestyle
but I know for a lot of people we need
to keep it into dollars and cents
initially yeah and that's how it works
so if it's 100 Grand and you divide it
by 2 000 then you divide it by four it
works out to about 12.50 some people be
like well I can't pay anybody do
anything meaningful for twelve dollars
and fifty cents truth is you can totally
there is so many services today you know
back in my day Sean when we both started
like you know there was there was
Craigslist there was like these sites
but now there's literally you can do
taskrabbit you can do upwork you can do
um you know even just paying somebody
deliver stuff to your house versus you
driving to go pick it up these are all
like little mental things that people
don't consider when they actually
analyze their calendar and do a chart
and energy audit that they could be
buying back their time but if you're
making a lot of clients I coach I mean
they're making half a million a year
plus yeah their buyback rates 62.50 yes
there's a lot of stuff they're doing in
their calendar they should just not be
doing anymore but even if you're maybe
working let's say a day job you got some
money coming in on your side hustle a
lot of people listening to this they're
trying to transition to being a
contentpreneur yeah you know and so if
we were to pick out something let's say
they're making 75 000 a year you got to
use your net number right you're talking
about your net so let's say you can net
75 000 what you're gonna do just to
break this down I got my calculator out
you're gonna a mulch you're gonna 75 000
divided by two thousand divide by two
thousand and so then that would mean how
much you make per hour and then divided
by four to get the four times Roi yeah
so then you make thirty seven dollars
and fifty cents per hour if you net 75
so when you work right now you're making
37.50 that's how much you keep that's
that's money then of course you got to
deploy that and if you're in the startup
phase you have to deploy that on rent or
your mortgage or your car payment or
whatever but lean and mean because you
should be reinvesting in your business
so then you divide that by four and
that's nine bucks it could be right
around ten bucks an hour you do have
onlinejobs.ph you you can have a
full-time dedicated virtual assistant 40
hours a week for about 700 bucks a month
that's that's wild and there's Services
we recommend things like vid shops or
video Huskies which allow you to Dropbox
your footage and I think they'll edit
four videos for you a month for a couple
hundred bucks so this can become
incredibly practical so the excuse of I
can't afford it is a mindset people have
to break it's a mindset it's a belief
busting moment it's a complexity ceiling
that they're just tapping against you
there's some other excuses what about
the one oh I don't have time though to
actually sit down and figure this out
that's my favorite one
um and the reason why is like I grew up
you know I read the e-myth when I was 23
I went all in you know I I hired an
email certified coach this guy named Bob
and then like as a software guy because
that's really what saved my life was
learning how to write code you know I
just I just fell in love with the ideas
of like repeatable systems and like I
read the book work the system by Sam
Carpenter checklist Manifesto those are
like my you know those are my books
here's what I discovered the problem
with a lot of like how to get somebody
to do something giving them a checklist
is it takes time because a lot of people
like I don't have time to create these
systems I don't know how to create these
systems so that's where I came up with
this thing called the camcorder method
in the camcorder method a lot of your
content creators can appreciate this is
I just record myself doing the work and
the only thing that's different is I
talk out loud about the thinking behind
what I'm doing so if I'm processing my
inbox I'm like and it's not entertaining
right it's me sitting there open up an
email and go oh that's by from Bob I
know Bob if I search my emails here's my
history with Bob so he's asking me for
15 minutes I'm gonna go and I look at my
calendar and it's like I only do
meetings in the afternoon so I'm going
to give them this 15 minute spot or I'm
going to send them my calendly link or
whatever it is and you just you just
talk yourself through doing this I mean
a lot of the camcorder method stuff I do
today like still this is a process I do
on a daily basis is either on my iPad
using the recorded with the audio so
I'll like draw stuff and I'll record
that to the cloud and then just share my
iCloud link or I'll jump on Zoom share
my screen and it's just me but I'm
recording it on Zoom because it's just
so easy and then my assistant can pick
it up and put it in a folder and so
essentially what I do is I record
everything knowing that I'm going to
eventually buy back that time and then
when I hire the person their first week
and it's not glamorous is watching 40
hours worth of content yeah but then
they create the SOP they create the
Playbook sop standard operating
procedure and what's cool about that is
they get to watch me do the work so it's
training they get to try to play this
game of like what is the pattern that I
should be seeing in the work and then
they document what they saw and through
that then I get a feedback loop at the
end of the week when I hire them so
Monday you start here's a document
that's got links all the recordings on
Dropbox go through that create the SOP
on Friday I get to see how well they
understood it so like last night I was
talking to this guy and he was like
nobody could edit like me and I go I
understand you believe that I would
actually run an experiment with you
where I'll pay for the editor and all
I'm going to do is have him go watch
your top five videos and I know a good
editor is not an idiot they're gonna
look at the videos and they're going to
go I see how he does this pinch I don't
even know this terminology but you know
what I mean he's gonna they're gonna see
it and I'm gonna have them write out an
sop for how you open how you transition
the music things the volume levels like
and they're just gonna write it out and
I bet they would do something that if
you showed a friend and said which of
these two edits do you think is a better
one they might pick the other person
yeah that moment I remember like when
you have somebody else produce work and
you weren't involved and I say this in
the book 80 done by somebody else is 100
freaking awesome yeah right but the
moment you have somebody actually do
work that's better than you would have
done why because that's the only thing
they're doing because they can take the
time to do it really well it's an unlock
for people it takes that ceiling of
complexity and just blows It Wide Open
so this is an ego this is offensive to
our egos because one of the other
excuses is no one can do as good at the
work as I can and and as a video editor
I struggled with this I actually thought
that as soon as I started working with
another editor his name was Jay at the
time when we finally got one of his
videos ready to release I thought that
was going to be the day that my YouTube
comments flooded with people saying you
betrayed us how dare you not edit your
own videos you sold out we are
unsubscribing and Dan can you guess how
many comments I got when a video edited
by somebody else came out on think media
as many as you had before and nobody
said anything and nobody said anything
zero comments and I just remember I've
been editing videos since 2003 so I had
you know it was one of my biggest skill
sets the truth is two things right no
one is as good at the work as I am
that's either a myth or if they can at
least do it eighty percent that's a
hundred percent freaking awesome yeah
because 80 percent is going to be
sufficient in creativity and in content
it's also kind of subjective yeah what
do you even mean what is a good edit
well is is it going to entertain people
do people like and enjoy it a lot of
creativity he could be really subjective
well and there's there's a framework I
teach in the book because I I did write
it for that when I wrote down the 25
people in my life that I love that I
knew were struggling with buying back
their time I pretty much like used them
as like okay what's their objection this
what's this okay and one of them was
this concept like I'm a creative what I
do is very nuanced nobody could do it as
good as me so I teach a few Concepts
like chunking but the one that people
really resonated with was the 1080 10
Rule and I watched Steve Jobs do this I
watched garyvee do this I watch a lot of
people that we admire build these
massive companies that you would argue
the product is innovation is creativity
it's it's it's it's it's sold musicians
and the 1080 10 rule is this is I'm
gonna spend the first 10 of a project
with the team to really talk about what
are we trying to do what is the story
arc what is the narrative structure what
is the resources we have access to what
do we think it should look like and if
Steve Jobs leaving his office and going
with Johnny Ives in the design studio
and just saying to Johnny like
I think we can get a hard drive that's
small enough to fit in the back of our
pockets and Johnny gone I don't think
those exist and he's like go see right
or hey what if we did a translucent
background on these iMacs or like like
lollipop colors and he's like they don't
make that kind of plastic go see right
it's that first 10 and then you know
Johnny would take these crazy requests
or ideas and then work with his team to
prototype and to pull out the CNC
machine and do foam models and all this
stuff and then they would eventually get
to a place where they had these finished
products but Steve would still come in
at the end that last 10 percent and
polish it right so that nothing ever
left the factory floor without his stamp
on it so that's what I'm saying to
people I'm not saying you delegate and
abdicate and just be like I hope it
works out yeah it's just take that 80
percent of the heavy lift in give it to
somebody else and then at the end you
can come in and look at the edit and go
like oh let's do this here let's do this
jump cup boom boom boom boom and then
the final product still has your essence
and soul and I think that framework has
helped a lot of creators go like oh I
can see how now I have these different
like work streams where I can still be
creative using the 1080 10 Rule and not
feel like I'm going to lose that that's
super powerful so the first 10 percent
you kind of are maybe giving the Genesis
idea the direction you're giving some
raw ingredients then 80 of the time
somebody else is doing the rest the
middle 80 and then in the final 10
you're tweaking it but you just bought
back eighty percent of your time yes and
so you have massive leverage created
there uh we're really onto something I
think speaking to creatives because
there's a unique resistance to this when
it comes to creativity and I think for
some uh like the Creator you were
speaking to last night many I speak to
who they just hold it so close their
creativity but there's an incredible
story about Andy Warhol the famous
artist right who produced something like
000 pieces of unique art in his career
yeah and that story really inspired me
in the book because it actually made me
think about you know what is my art and
when I think about these videos it is it
is video it is I think I've uploaded
over 2 000 videos now we're now doing
vertical video and we're doing around
328 pieces of content a week this is all
insane there's no way this is happening
if there wasn't 18 people working at
think media and 10 contractors and
systems
um but clearly it is not my hand on 80
or even it might be less than that of
the work and Andy Warhol was seminal
similar this is an actual artist an
actual who's doing painting or silk
screening break down that story of of of
what he did that maybe creatives that
have a resistance to like letting go of
their creativity might have yeah I mean
this is the fun part and it's why I use
those examples in the book okay I didn't
use Elon Musk I didn't use Mark
Zuckerberg I didn't use all these Tech
entrepreneurs I said no let's go to the
most creative art forms art Tom Clancy
yeah Oprah right these people that
you're like oh they're just so crazy
Steve Jobs right but how do you do that
scale so so here's Andy Warhol and he
figured out something when he looked at
how he produced his art and what was
valuable to the art he realized a few
things one me being out with potential
buyers telling them the stories of my
art and my life that's actually what
makes art valuable it's a great book
called Austin
um show your work by Austin Cleon yeah
um I love it I'm not even an artist per
se you know I do business stuff but I
love the idea of like understanding what
what we do that creates value because
that's in in the book I make this strong
argument of like replace your time fill
it once you buy it back with things that
light you up that actually move your
business forward that you would do like
the whole part of a building Empire is
creating a life that you never have to
retire from with unlimited creativity so
Andy Warhol saw that hey my time should
be better spent talking to customers and
coming up with creative ideas as a play
with so he created this thing called the
factory and he had like a dozen interns
that he would walk in he would do
essentially the 1080 10 rule where he
would be like I got this crazy idea
let's do this treatment on these
photographer this photography or
whatever and like do a bunch of
variations right and I think that's the
if anybody's stuck on this about their
creativity creative output I would
actually argue that you will do more
creativity I think you'll have more to
it's like almost like more taste making
you'll be able to have more to look at
you have a team and they're showing you
stuff and they're like hey I found this
really cool site that lets us get these
kind of audio clips and you're like oh
and then you as the creative can can be
the person that does the remixes right
that goes I wonder if we took that audio
output and paired it with this visual
treatment how would that look and
instead of you having to do it they
literally can do it while you go to your
next meeting you know you might go close
a new sponsor or you know do the thing
only you can do be on this show right
yeah but like the way I think about it
and what Andy inspire me Tom Clancy I
mean he just so people know Tom Clancy's
dead and he still writes best-selling
books wow think about that idea yeah he
still writes best-selling books he is no
longer here on Earth why because they
built a system around his creative
output and a lot of people like I
remember I only found this out because I
watched the pilot I was at the lounge in
Toronto at the airport and he was
reading this book and it was like thick
and I was like wow that's Tom Clancy
like he goes yeah it's crazy because
he's not even alive yeah like he's not
alive he's like no he died like 10 years
ago and I was like and you still read
the book he goes I really like the book
wow I like the format I like the
structure I like that type of of writing
and they found people that could
essentially
um replicate his voice in his structure
and I think that's the part that it
attacks the ego yeah right but I would
argue that what I would love for every
creative and I've and all the podcasters
I've talked to is like I want you to be
on air that's your unique genius the way
you show up you you ask questions and
you engage with the but as soon as the
cameras are done move on and and build a
team that can take all this stuff and
then just and then just have it show up
on social media show up you know and and
support the sponsors do all this stuff
and I think that's and then do more of
that right like buy back your time to go
produce other shows like you're doing
like you know and just look at look at
this stuff because I think it's I don't
know I just can't see a world where
somebody's truly about their art in
creating that a future where they don't
create more isn't what they want the
only bottleneck is they're doing stuff
that isn't actually part of the creative
process they can't get support on yeah
and that story inspired me I actually
thought I'm like think media our goal is
to make it like the factory like how do
we scale creativity how do we also
enroll other creatives you know increase
our outputs and what's fascinating is
that Andy Warhol it wasn't just the art
that he figured out he really developed
the skill of business and he developed
the skill of systems and so sometimes as
YouTube content creators or as business
owners trying to pump out more content
we don't think about that as much but
that's really where the game is and
that's a lot of the value you add in
this book I want to go back to just
giving us some practical handles for
getting control of our time of our week
and maybe looking at maybe just some
self-awareness where we're wasting time
but also what we should hire first and
you recommend people do a time and
energy audit a lot of people recommend
time audits you add on energy what's the
difference and how much of a window of a
time should we do and what do you think
we will discover in that how do we do
that as yeah well I kind of alluded to
it earlier like the energy part is
actually the missing piece and
especially creatives like if I'm if I'm
super creative for two hours and then I
gotta jump on an hour call with my like
accountant man try to get you back into
the creatives like it's just so so you
know I think what was interesting when
you talk to like you watch a Dr Dre talk
about being in the studio or like they
just lose track of time you know I used
to call it art class like when I'd go to
art class the Bell would ring and 45
seconds what felt like 45 seconds later
which was an hour the belt ring again
and I just lost track of time I would
love for everybody to look at their
calendar through that lens what would
change how would you show up for your
family for your team if you were giving
yourself permission because that's what
it is because I'm I'm really trying to
convince that's why I wrote the
five-time Assassins it's like I want to
give people permission to edit their
calendar through this lens and the way
it works is and this is the first thing
I do with all my private coaching
clients is two-week audit every 15
minutes you can get by these little
timers if you want or use your phone but
essentially every 15 minute goes off and
you got to write down what you just
worked on and you do that for two weeks
and it sounds like super tedious and it
is but it's by Design Because by the
second day people are like wow I'm
wasting a lot of time but keep doing it
get that two-week audit because it gives
you enough of a visual into your
calendar to see and then you go back and
you highlight green if it gave you
energy that you enjoyed doing it or read
if it took energy from you and then you
score it out of one dollar sign over
four dollar signs kind of like the cost
of a restaurant one dollar sign is
essentially your buyback rate and four
dollar signs is kind of like what you
normally would have like what you make
per hour that you'd have to pay somebody
else it's like 62.50 or 100 an hour that
might be a four dollar sign a rating and
it's either one or four so it could be
two it could be three or whatever and
when you step back and you look at this
audit this time and energy audit and you
grab all the red stuff and all the one
dollar stuff that's red and you put it
into a bucket you get excited because
you're like holy moly what if I hired
somebody to do that and it might be one
person it could be three part time I
call it out tasking it doesn't matter
how you solve it but you should not this
is my argument you should not spend a
dollar on paying another person to
support you other than that and that is
literally that Rhythm I talk about the
buyback Loop in the book I run through
that Rhythm for me probably three times
a year where I'm I'm adding so much to
my plate that it does get to a point
where I blow things up and then I have
to sit down with my assistant and say
like okay let's redesign my calendar
through this lens just recently last
week I I'm involved in a company and I
was joining their senior leadership team
meeting which is all the directors
talking about like strategy and focus
you know and after a few years like it
started to become yellow and then it
eventually became red and I just talked
to the CEO and I said I'm probably not
going to come to that meeting anymore
yeah and you know what he's like that's
cool and and it was just like all of a
sudden now I've got this 90 minute
window back on my calendar to fill up
with things that are gonna light me up
in green and like do more talking about
the book or supporting entrepreneurs or
whatever it is and it's just like for me
to go from a meeting that's even yellow
it just affects my headspace and I just
think there's so much more output that
could be had if people I would argue
this is the number like people like well
how valuable is this I think it's a 3X
increase in your output wow a 3X your
creativity goes up your ability to to
just think about somebody and then just
like text them and then all of a sudden
there's a collab happening right like I
really think that if you go from
anything that's red or yellow like in
your calendar to just green just doing
the things that light you up you will
actually amplify because it creates
momentum and energy that is a 3X
amplifier and I think I saw a piece of
content from you
I've heard a lot from our community
a myth in hiring and you could tell me
if you believe it's a myth they want to
kind of do this mindless hiring I just
want to hire somebody to even think
about everything for me do everything
for me and they might think I need an
operations manager I need I need to hire
a CEO and then they have uh no there's
not a lot of momentum yet there's maybe
money coming in but what you're you're
saying no actually flip it like if you
just did that time and energy audit and
got rid of just the one dollar signs a
lot more affordable to go admin
assistant obviously than a six-figure by
a fourth or a fifth and and a lot of
people think that they just kind of want
to dump the whole thing yeah and and
they probably can't afford it or would
you also they're not even to a place of
sophistication well that's what's
necessary they don't have enough in
place I mean I call it the you know in
the book I talk about this pain line
right most entrepreneurs when they get
to the pain line and it's different
stages for different people it could be
at 50 Grand in Revenue it could be at
100 300 whatever and at that point they
decide to do one or three things I call
them the three s's right they either
decide to sell hey Dan I don't want to
do this I'm going to sell I'm going to
go into something else right I'm in I
mean in real estate it's like I'm
wholesaling I want to go into airbnbs
right
um or they decide to stall I I made more
money last year right so like they grew
this year they grew their agency and all
of a sudden they're like hating their
calendar their life their time and
they're making less money so they're
like I'm gonna go backwards
problem is is your customers aren't
going backwards your your best players
on your team they ain't cool with Stalin
they have a vision for their life
they're hoping you're going to support
and if they feel like you're not growing
they're gonna go find some other
companies your best people leave but the
third one is sabotage and sabotage is a
fascinating one right where
sometimes when they hit the pain line
you know instead of actually digging in
and doing a time and energy audit they
do these crazy things like I'm gonna I'm
gonna shut down all my products I'm
gonna hire a CO I'm gonna like and I
actually step back and I go it's not a
logical decision it's an emotional
decision and it's a sabotage that's
going to give you ground cover to to to
to downsize yeah like it's actually they
don't know it but I've just been doing
this for so long I've got like 10 000
hours of watching entrepreneurs make
really funny decisions yeah um they're
hand grenades they throw a hand grenade
like hire a CO when they can't afford it
and or or they'll hire like I had a
friend of mine Nate the other day he's
like you know I read your book awesome
hiring a salesperson and I'm like oh
because I have this whole replacement
ladder I talk about the sequencing sales
is fourth out of level one two three
four I go how many sales calls you do in
a week he's like four you don't have
enough like yeah but I'm not saying
anything like I'm the lighthouse I'm
just like okay you might want to reread
the book because here's what's going to
happen you hire salesperson and in three
or four months one or two things are
going to happen either you fire them
because he's not making any money
because you don't have enough leads
anyway uh he's not going to be able to
sell at the same win rate you're doing
today because you're showing up with so
much enthusiasm the person's buying
because of you they will be going from
call to call not making any sales
because there's not enough volume to
create momentum right great sales people
literally need to do five six calls a
day because they need that Rhythm the
first cause nobody sells the first call
of the day they need to go through it
they got to get the ramped up it's
almost like an engine turning over and
so like people make these sabotaging
decisions like you know they read a book
and they're like I gotta hire a CEO it's
like you don't even have an assistant
sure like let's start there this
complexity is really high yeah but I
always look at it as like they're
throwing a hand grenade in their
business to sabotage themselves from not
having to do the thing to push through
that pain line so that's also one of my
favorite chapters the replacement ladder
and of course the book will be linked up
in the show notes it's pretty wild and
it's only been out six weeks at the time
of recording this over 150 five-star
reviews I understand why got the whole
book marked up I can't believe that that
blew my brain and uh and it's just
absolute gold I also want to encourage
you know like you said you wrote this
for those that are very far along on
business and there's a lot that listen
to this that are at six multiple six and
some seven figure earners but a lot of
people are also at that beginning stage
and I always encourage people to be
learning above your weight class you
know and to be learning to delegate
learning to build a team learning to
hire before you're ready you know and
thinking about those things so highly
recommend that but what is your advice
for those that are in the side hustle or
the startup season if you're listening
to this people have jumped on this very
real opportunity of building a business
in the crater economy I think tube
filters said 200 million people have
earned money in the crater economy uh
influencer marketing Hub said I think 2
million are earning six figures and they
they didn't develop software they don't
have a product or maybe eventually they
have merch or something but it's this I
this this new very real signal fire said
this is the fastest growing type of
small business 100 the being a content
creator and so for those that are in
that side hustle startup season you know
they're not they probably didn't get
funding they're bootstrapping so they
have a day job and they're trying to get
from there to you know being able to do
this full-time from that perspective
what would you say to them Dan one thing
pick a budget and just buy back some
time like I really think it's that
simple I had a client and they just
couldn't get their heads wrapped around
having a house cleaner sounds crazy to
any of us that do but it's just like for
whatever reason like having a stranger
in their home was a tough thing their
wife wasn't on board and I just like
look just grab 200 bucks hire somebody
do it for two months if you don't like
it stop
but at least you know my friend Brad his
dad had this great song saying that said
the person with experience is never at
the mercy of the person with an opinion
if you don't try it's an opinion it's
not facts yeah so I would just recommend
it doesn't matter what stage you're at
just force yourself to go learn the
skill of delegating go learn the scale
of a camcorder method go learn the skill
of having somebody support some element
of your creative output right and just
realize that that muscle today even
though it'll be super small and weak the
more you practice it the more you invest
in it the more it grows as you grow your
art your creative your output is going
to be on the on the recipient side of
that it's going to benefit from doing
that and there's just no person that any
Creator admires from the Logan Paul's to
you name it that hasn't figured this out
yeah it's part of the equation don't
wait too long to figure it out where you
grow a business or a side hustle that
you eventually hate doing because you
have and figured that part out you have
built this YouTube channel you're going
to be getting your silver play button
soon soon very right right on the verge
of 100 000 subscribers a lot of
entrepreneur friends of mine that are
like you really want to crack the code
on YouTube
um and they haven't what do you think uh
and my diagnosis and I'm sure you have
your own but a lot of times they're also
not being very consistent there or they
are not investing a ton of effort from
your perspective what has been your
mindset towards YouTube and what systems
have you built around your YouTube
channel that has led you as much more
primarily a business owner
growing such a big YouTube influence
yeah so the the thing that's unique
about my YouTube channel is I started it
for my two boys like I moved to San
Francisco or San Diego
um for the winter months this would have
been nine eight eight nine years ago and
then I met a bunch of creators like
because it's kind of the mecca for like
online seminar people my buddy Travis
was like you should do video because I
had this company called clarity.fm and I
did a bunch of speaking and he's like I
would love to watch your take on this
stuff but that wasn't enough motivation
for me it was really the idea when a
friend of mine Todd you know called me
up one day and essentially got diagnosed
with the terminal illness and I said
well dude how do you deal with that
because he had three little girls same
age as my boys and he goes I already
shot the videos
and I was like whoa and in that moment I
was like well I don't want to find out
or it be too late I'm just gonna start
shooting videos if you go back to the
early days of my YouTube channel it was
like how to discover your passion how to
you know just in time learning like it
was literally like inspired by maxino
and my two boys and then over time I
just ran out of stuff that I was I was
recording for them and then just kept
evolving into business advice and and
honestly today I take every question I
get asked on social media in my inbox
and that drives my content really from
everything from like how do you raise
Venture Capital to how do you exit your
company to how do you hire an executive
assistant so the benefit for me of
producing that channel wasn't a business
focus more of a I just want to answer
all these questions and then have a link
I can send people to and if I were to
audit like if I wanted let's say a
million subscribers the two things that
I would have done sooner we started
doing this recently
um is up up leveling the edits right and
really adding the dynamic system like
there's just a like the stuff that all
creators are doing today right watching
Mr Beast like just doing what the best
people do like Mr Beast I believe he
said like within every second and a half
or three seconds there's there's a
there's an edit there's a changes of
this so we started doing that the other
thing is collaborations right like I
used to coach Layla and Alex hermosi and
other residents of Vegas and watching
Alex literally just come on the scene
because we used to talk about this
before we ever had a meaningful YouTube
channel he had his podcast the game and
he did publish stuff but just deciding
to go all in and then I watched what he
did which was the collabs
do you like I don't know if you know
this Sean but like I've never done this
before isn't this nuts I've never been
on another YouTuber's YouTube channel
sure I've been on podcasts but they
weren't YouTubers yeah yeah and what's
interesting is I watch Alex do this he
came out of nowheres and he was on like
25 different YouTube see this is a thing
as platforms are platforms so somebody
that watches YouTube if they see you and
you have a YouTube channel they'll go
yeah right and a podcaster will go
listen like a Joe Rogan listener we'll
go listen to like the dyer of a CEO
right that's more podcast based and it's
interesting watching even just like
content output and media channels like
you you see these some some podcasts
that have huge audiences and then their
YouTube channel has like 80 000 Subs
it's like but you have millions of
listeners it's it's fascinating and
Oprah talked about this one she goes
when she left her TV daytime TV show and
she started uh her own network she said
I underestimated the power of the medium
and a time slot right she owned I think
it was a 4 30 PM eastern time slot right
like Mom's making dinner whatever maybe
it's three o'clock in the afternoon but
that's what I would do different is and
I'm doing it now is the collabs and the
edits and also content that might be a
little bit more entertainment than just
educational like even Layla hermosis
she's actually one of the blurbs on the
back because her and I've always jammed
on the operation side of things yeah and
and my content was very like very busy
and now I'm trying to add a little bit
more entertainment to it I'm trying to
make it a lot more fun I'm trying to
make it broader appeal to people
starting off and not just folks that are
running a bigger companies which is what
I did predominantly because that's that
was my customers those are my audiences
and how much content do you create in
your system for it like when are you
shooting and how many people are working
we do batch video we um today and I'll
unpack as much as I can know because I
have a team that manages it but
essentially we shoot probably four to
five times a year we batch so multiple
shirts changes I jump on they're on Zoom
I'm in my office I have two cameras
recording me all day long so there's the
YouTube content which we we actually
shoot and there's an outline for each
video and then there's literally I think
I I asked my videographer this morning
how much backlog content we have to work
there's 150 hours wow because I record
all my board meetings I record all my
team meetings I record all my coaching
calls I record all my podcast interviews
and then the team goes through that
identify clips and put them out so
um on the back ends of my creative
director Sam my videographers my video
editors I think there's a team of five
people part-time some of them just
producing content and we're going to be
ramping that up quite a bit killer uh
amazing and so much nuggets there
especially with the batching and
recording when you're on podcasts are
you ready for the lightning round as we
land the plane ready probably not but
excited yes this is actually just
getting your take on um some different
topics especially I'm fascinated to hear
what you think everyone is talking about
Ai and many people are afraid they think
it's going to be a massive disrupter
what's your opinion on chat gbt AI my
context is this I've been coding in AI
neural nets for a while so I'm deep in
the technology and the learning models
and there's no
um there's very few people I would put
uh you know Pierre diamandis and a
handful of people that are at the
Forefront because I literally my call
after this I'm on the board of a company
that's building essentially coaching AI
so essentially in the future generative
video generative audio of a coach with
their content catalog plugged into GPT I
probably lost some people but whatever
um Here's my thought every company every
role in the world will have a co-pilot
AI for their role a video editor will
have a co-pilot we're already seeing
this stuff it's it's happening at such a
pace like literally on a daily basis
somebody's sending me a link to another
AI tool like rewind.ai which records
everything you say on your screen and in
your office recorded locally so nobody
sees it encrypted but then you can
literally have perfect recall that's
today that's available the video stuff
of like the plugins that allow me to be
looking off screen and it resets my eyes
like the the amount of so so that's what
I call the co-pilot of the work so a
lawyer co-pilot AI there's already
programming co-pilot it's literally
allowing software developers to be three
times more productive while they write
code because as they're writing you know
like type ahead in your email it
literally predicts what you think you're
gonna write and it asks you and you just
hit go and it writes all the code for
you so the future of AI for me is
incredibly unknown and it's gonna be
what it's going to be like it's going to
be disruptive to a lot of people that
are deciding to not lean into it a
little bit but the ones that jump on it
like GPT and 3.5 which came out in
November versus 4-0 4-0 is a hundred
times better than 3.5 geez so if we're
impressed with chat GPT today yeah wait
do you agree with Elon Musk that thinks
that AI is super dangerous super
dangerous you think it's dangerous yeah
I think it's dangerous and what gives me
hope open AI was actually a non-profit
that Elon kind of founded with Sam
Altman from Y combinator and I knew the
whole Genesis story and they've been
working on it for six years seeing my
Microsoft come in and write those kind
of checks to like own part of it or
whatever the weird financing deal was
was concerning but then there's other
projects luckily that are competing
against chat GPT that are open source so
I'm feeling better about that and if I
if I didn't see that I would be super
concerned so now that doesn't mean there
shouldn't be some level of governance at
the federal government level to make
sure that the apples of Facebook the
Amazons who really have the best
opportunity to create you know like
General Ai and like some really
dangerous potential things to not create
what they need is somebody to kind of
think about like driving cars like
there's rules about how roads work we
need that for AI or cars will smash into
each other AI has that potential of
going from like super cool to absolutely
chaotic if it's not properly managed if
you had only one social media platform
um where would you invest your time Tick
Tock Instagram Facebook YouTube
Somewhere Else starting today
um the only reason I wouldn't say Tick
Tock is because I'm uncertain about how
the government's going to respond to it
I do think Tick Tock I hope I don't get
Shadow banned somehow from whatever who
cares there is some government back-end
stuff that I'm concerned about as a
software technical person
um I think I always like to go to the
one that's got the most traction but
it's still underdeveloped and Tick Tock
is definitely one of those it's just no
matter what platform You're Building
collect the email addresses build an
audio like the amount of people that
have a YouTube channel like Tim Ferriss
used to be this guy he used to have a
Blog I remember meeting Tim and I was
like Tim you need an email address it
was until ramit seti finally sat him
down and said Tim you have to collect an
email on your blog traffic and
eventually he did it now he has a two
million person email address wow when
you have a two million person email
address and you own that then Tick Tock
decides government shuts Tick Tock down
no worries I'm gonna go launch the next
thing and I'm gonna I have the access to
the audience so I think like yeah I
think Tick Tock would be the one if I if
I wasn't concerned about the government
I'm a big fan of Instagram I still love
Instagram stories I think there's a lot
of opportunity YouTube shorts are really
fascinating so yeah I'd be a toss-up
between Tick Tock and YouTube but
regardless lead like collect an email
and build a relationship with your your
audience Business Insider just dropped
an article that said why it's always a
good time to start a business despite
inflation layoffs and a possible
recession Americans created 10.5 million
businesses in the past two years
according to Census Bureau data and that
momentum is expected to continue in 2023
despite inflation layoffs and recession
fears what is your take on the current
state of the economy entrepreneur
actually called this the year of fear
and uncertainty yet the ambitious and
Risk Takers are still stepping out what
is your thought of the current economic
state with inflation shrinking back
going on offense what's your take two
things all business economy value
Creation in the world has nothing to do
with the economy and has everything to
do with mindset like it's just that
simple they're they're I think I looked
the other day 5.1 trillion dollars of
the economy change hands today 5.1
trillion go get a piece of that yeah go
figure out how to do it that has nothing
to do with the economy that has to do
with your psychology your mindset your
habits your beliefs your your character
traits the second thing is
um this guy Keith were boy very well
known in Silicon Valley was early at
PayPal and square he was a CEO of square
he's one of the top investors he said
this to me I met him in 2008 and I said
um you know Keith when I look at like
the Googles the paypals and all these
other companies Facebook they were all
started in a downward economy why do you
think that is and he said it's very
simple he goes during those downturns
you have an increase in IQ per square
foot and I said what do you mean he goes
if we would have started PayPal today in
2007 2008 all the smartest people the
the Sam the Sam Lev's Chans and the the
max this and all these people they
mentioned Reed Hoffman Elon Musk they
would have been doing their own thing
they would be in y combinated there
would have been this accelerator they've
been doing stuff because the economy was
compressed we had the ability to attract
world-class Talent so the IQ per square
foot went up and that's why you see
literally their stats around the best
companies are started in a downward
economy it also allows you to because
people are like that are willing to join
this like crazy idea when the economy is
not good you're attracting a certain
type of person that when the market
comes back it's a slingshot effect so I
tell everybody like over the next two
years giddy up if you're looking to
start I would start right now where
maybe Labor's cheaper I mean I went for
the last five years hiring people I felt
like I was on the receiving end of what
have you done for me lately I want three
times more you know per year and now
it's like oh now it's fair and I think
like this is a great time to start and
build a foundation and a platform to
take advantage of this upswing and
that's that's just the reality and
that's the stats Dan Martell shout out
your stuff thank you so much for adding
so much value today of course everyone's
got to pick up a copy of buy back your
time it'll be a great investment you
mentioned in the book you had an unlock
that you could get 20 years of
somebody's experience and wisdom and the
mistakes they've made for twenty dollars
that's why we love reading lifelong
leaders or lifelong Learners and so of
course we're going to link up the book
in the show notes but if people want to
follow you anything else you're working
on shout it out yeah so Instagram
stories is where I actually show the
behind the scenes of my life that I try
to be an example of everything I teach
in this book so if you guys are curious
about that YouTube is where I teach
everything the how-to content and then
I'm on Twitter Tick Tock no no crop top
dances on Tick Tock more business
content and if you have any feedback for
me like your audience are great creators
like I'm always looking for talent I'm
always looking for feedback I'm always
looking for strategies I'm a learner and
I'm a big fan of people so Reach Out
grateful thank you so much for coming on
the think media podcast my owner man
it's awesome